RETO MEIER: Today,
I learned where
rats like to hang out when
they're in New York City.
And which neighborhoods complain
too much, and which too little,
about seeing furry
rodent visitors.
I'm Reto Meier, Google
Developer Advocate.
Join me as I upload and then
investigate the New York City
rodent inspection data
set with BigQuery.
Using the 311 one table from
the New York City public data
sets in BigQuery, we can see a
dramatic increase in complaints
about rats starting in 2013.
If we bucket those
reports into locations,
we can even create
a heat map that
shows just the density
of rat sightings reported
across the city.
But that only tells
us part of the story.
To better understand the true
extent of rats in New York,
we need to get more data.
New York City Open
Data Project includes
this table of written
inspections across the five
boroughs.
We're going to load
that data into BigQuery.
We'll start by downloading the
CSV file, and while we're here,
let's grab the data dictionary
and import that into Google
Sheet so we can use the schema.
Now we go back to BigQuery.
Select a data set and
press the plus symbol
to create a new table.
For small files
up to 10 megs, you
can upload it here directly.
But our vermin table
is around 200 megs,
so instead we'll upload it to
Google Cloud Storage first.
You can also import
data from Google Drive,
but we'll save that
for another episode.
Once we have a location for
our newly uploaded rodent table
CSV, we'll return to
BigQuery and enter that,
as well as providing a
name for our new table.
Then it's just a case
of specifying a schema
by adding the name and
type of each column.
We'll use the data
dictionary we imported
into Google Sheets earlier as
a guide for the column names
and to get the
corresponding data types.
We won't need all of these
columns for our analysis,
but there's no cost
for importing data
so we can happily
pool it all in now
and then trim our table later.
In this table, it turns
out that the time stamp
format used in the CSV file
isn't compatible with BigQuery.
So we'll treat it as a string
for the initial import.
Once the import job is done,
we can review the new table.
Let's immediately
use it as a source
of creating another table.
This one will include
only the columns we need,
latitude, longitude, borough
inspection, type, and results.
And convert the time stamp
strings into real time stamps.
Once we save the
results to a new table,
we can delete the CSV file from
Cloud Storage and the larger
original import table.
BigQuery charges $0.02
per gig, per month,
pro-rated each second.
The table we're going
to use is only 63 megs,
so we'd need to keep it
for almost eight months
before we got charged a
full cent for using it.
With that in mind, we're all set
to continue our investigation.
We'll start by finding the total
number of inspections conducted
each year.
We can see a trend
similar to the 311
calls over the past three years,
but with an odd bump in 2012.
One of the advantages
of using this new table
is that it also includes
inspection results.
We can see that about 75% of
the time, the initial inspection
actually passes.
Now if we limit our
results to inspections
that find active
rat signs, we can
see that the 2012
bump corresponds
to a significant increase in
inspections, but not in rats.
That's not the case in 2016,
increases across the board.
But New York is a big city.
If we examine the
trends per borough,
looking only to inspections
that found active rat signs,
we can see that while there
was an uptick across the board,
Manhattan and Brooklyn
are definitely
catching up to the Bronx,
crowned rat capital in 2011.
We can continue
our investigation
by using the locations of
each specific inspection
to create heat maps telling
which neighborhoods have
the most rat signs and what
the current trends suggest
for the future of
rats in New York.
Check out the blog post listed
in the description below
to see where those
investigations lead.
BigQuery includes a range
of public data sets,
including over 130 gigabytes
of New York City data,
including calls to the 311
municipal complaints line.
As always, your first byte
of data processing each month
is free.
Go to BigQuery today to
import your own data sets
and share the results with
us using the TILwBQ hashtag.
And tune in each week to
learn more about BigQuery
with tips and tricks.
Subscribe to the Google
Cloud YouTube channel
and follow our blog to learn
something new with BigQuery.